Hello world, it's Saroj and Crypto
kitties. Have you played it yet?
It's this blockchain based
game that's gone viral.
It sparked a global craze
for collecting cartoon cats.
We're going to cover how it works
programmatically in this video.
There's even a Chinese language
mobile app which was just released.
Bringing the game to
large parts of East Asia.
Looks like the great firewall
is not so great, Huh?
Crypto kitties is built on the ethereum
blockchain at one point in accounted for
a third of all transactions
on the etherium network,
which is insane if and when the
Chinese market for the game grows.
It's not certain that the ethereum
network could handle that many users,
but both the theory and Crypto
Kitty's team are working out issues of
scalability.
Currently crypto kitties,
our collective cats like Pokemon or beanie
babies, but unlike those collectibles,
these cats breed,
they can create offspring with unique
DNA preserved in the blockchain.
Over 500 k Kitty's have been sold so
far and there are about 250 k players.
We transactions are passing $40 million.
The rarest crypto Kitty's have sold over
north of a hundred k and some are worth
over 300 k. The crypto Kitty's
code is open source. It's
about 2000 lines of code.
The smart contract language
of ethereum solidity.
Remember this is all code
that lives on the blockchain,
so every node in the theory of network
story's a copy of it. It's a lot of code,
but we can go over the most important
parts to try and understand how it works.
So the way the game works is that
it's a way for players to buy, sell,
and breed digital cats.
Every cat has its own unique appearance.
It's defined by its DNA.
When a player breeds to cats,
their genes combined in a unique way,
and this produces an offspring which
a player can then breed again or sell
cleverly. The code for Crypto kitties
is split into several smart contracts,
so it's not one giant messy
file with all the code in.
It will see that there exists a
subcontract called inheritance in the main
crypto kitty contract with the
listing of all the contracts.
Kitty Corp is the main contract address
that the APP points too and we can see
that it inherits all the data and
functions from previous contracts.
We can walk through each of
these contracts to better
understand how they work.
Let's start at the lowest level.
Kitty access control and move our way up.
The kitty access control contract manages
the various addresses and constraints
for operations that can be
executed only by specific roles.
There are three roles currently. These
pertained to the creators of the game.
They have special ownership and control
over particular functions of the
contract. It defines some
function modifiers like only CEO,
which restricts to a function so that
only the CEO can perform it and adds
functions to perform actions like
pause or release contract funds.
The pause function is interesting.
It allows the developers to freeze the
contract completely making it so no one
can transfer a sell or breed or kitties.
It's probably not in their
best interest to do that,
but it's just something to note.
Just because it's built on the blockchain,
it doesn't mean control is
completely decentralized.
It just made completely
transparent in this case.
When we move on to the
Kitty base function,
we defined the most fundamental code
shared throughout the core functionality,
the game where and how
is our user data stored?
What are the constants and
the data types we'll use?
What are the internal functions
for managing these items?
It first it finds a kitty as a struct.
It's essentially a bunch of unsigned
integers that are its features.
The genes represent its DNA.
What it ends up looking like,
birth time tells us when the cap was born,
cooled down and block is the timestamp
after which this cat can start breeding
again, may train NCI or id
or the ideas of the cats.
Parents Syring with ID is the ID of the
father and cooled down is how long the
cat has to wait before breeding again.
Lastly,
generation tells us which
generation the cat is of.
We'll see that there exists an array
of these kitties trucks that were just
defined. This array will hold the data
of every single crypto kitty that exists.
It's like a master kitty database.
Whenever some new cat is born,
it's added to the array and its index
in the right acts as its ID genesis,
the first crypto kitty as
an idea of one for example,
the contract also has a mapping from
the cats id to the address of its owner
that keep track of who
a kitty is owned by,
so whenever a kitty is given
from one player to another,
the kitty index you own or mapping gets
updated accordingly to reflect its new
owner.
When a new kitty has created the ids
of the mother and father as well as its
genetic code are used. See how a
crypto kitty is its own data type.
All these cats are stored
on the blockchain and who
owns which cap is also kept
track of, we call them kitty's but
they can also be considered tokens.
There are several token specs
written for Ethereum Erc,
20 being the most popular use
for initial coin offerings,
but crypto Kitty's conforms to Erc seven
21 this is a non fungible token type
that's really useful for tracking
ownership of digital collectibles,
like where game items per digital pets.
Ether is considered a fungible token
because any two ether is just as valuable
as the other,
but with a non fungible token,
not all cats are created equal so they're
not interchangeable with each other.
Since one breed could be
much more rare than another.
The kitty ownership contract inherits
from Erc seven 21 and all of these tokens
follow the same standard.
Kitty ownership fills in the
implementation of the ERC 21 functions.
A player can transfer their tokens to
someone else by interacting directly with
the crypto Kitty's contract on the
ethereum blockchain without having to go
through their web interface.
Moving up one level to kitty breeding.
This is the contract that has the
functions necessary to breed cats together
like keeping track of breeding offers
and notice that there is a separate
contract called gene science that is
not open source that's used to calculate
how new DNA is created.
It seems like the reason that kept this
part closed source is because if it
wasn't anyone could just read helicase
DNA was determined and it would be a lot
easier to know which cats to
breed in order to get a fancy cat.
When two cats are bred together, it looks
them up in the master kitty's array,
sets the ideas to the mother and father's
and executes trigger cool down on both
parents so they can't breed again
for a certain amount of time.
Then the give birth function creates a
new cat by determining the child's genes.
Then using gene science dot mixed
genes and calling create kitty.
Now that we know how
these cats are created,
we can move up to the
kitty auctions contract,
which tells us how to auction or
bid on cats or breeding services.
This contract has certain
functions like set sail,
auction address that can
only be called by the CEO.
Then in the kitty mentoring contract,
it defines the rules for how a
generation of cats are created.
The number of promote cats, the number
of cats in generation zero is hard coded.
The Coo can even create Promo
kitties and generate new kitties.
This is probably for use with early Beta
testers and friends and family. Finally,
we can move up to kitty core,
the master contract.
This is what is compiled and run on the,
if they're in blockchain,
it inherits from all previous
contracts we looked at.
It also adds a few more final
functions like the get kitty function,
which retrieves all of the crypto Kitty's
data using its ID. You might be asking,
where are all these wonderful cat images
stored? I don't see any code for that.
Correct.
A crypto kitty is essentially just a 256
bit integer that represents his genetic
code. The solidity contract code has
nothing in it that stores a cat's image or
description that happens on
the Crypto kitties web server.
This architecture choice was
likely to avoid blockchain bloat.
Storing lots of images on
a blockchain is a bad idea.
It could quickly add up to too much
reminders to store on their local machines
and transactions could grind to a halt.
It does introduce a single point
of failure, their web server,
but a future version could instead use
the decentralized file storage network
IPFS to store data so that no
single entity can store the data.
Instead, it's a network of computers,
but that's a video for another day.
Three things to remember from this video.
Crypto kitties is a mostly open source
game that runs on the ethereum blockchain
allowing players to buy, sell,
and breed collectible cats.
The code is written in solidity and
helps define functions per how cats are
created, what their features are, and
how a player can interact with them.
And because the image data
is stored on a web server,
it's not completely decentralized.
Although IPFS could be a
better alternative to that.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I'm going to trade some cats,
so thanks for watching.